48 ساعة مضطربة في
الأسواق المالية والتي ستشمل النفط
بسبب مخاوف من انخفاض
الطلب بسبب فيروس كورونا خاصة
في آسيا
أخبرني وزير الطاقة السعودي أن الوقت ليس
للرضا عن النفس وأن هناك اجتماعًا طارئًا
الأسبوع المقبل في فيينا بين أوبك
واللاعبين من خارج أوبك ، لكن ماذا يعني ذلك
بالنسبة للمصدرين الرئيسيين في الشرق الأوسط الذين
تحدثت إلى أكبرهم جميعًا
أرامكو السعودية ، كان الرئيس التنفيذي أمين ناصر
في جلستي وقال إن النصف الأول
من العام سيظل يمثل تحديًا خطيرًا
دعنا  أقول إنني أعتقد أنه
قصير الأجل أولاً وقبل كل شيء ، من
الممكن أن يكون هناك مشكلة في النصف الثاني ،
سيكون واثقًا من انتهاء هذا الأمر
ليس شيئًا جديدًا أو شيئًا لم نمر
به عبر
تاريخنا الذي كنا عليه  من خلال هذه
الدورات مرات عديدة ، نتكيف
جيدًا لإدارة كل ما يتطلبه
الموقف ، لذلك ترى
أنه تحدٍ في النصف الأول يمكن
إزالته في النصف الثاني من  هذا العام ، هذه
هي وجهة نظرنا بعض التوجيهات الجديدة من
الرئيس التنفيذي لشركة أرامكو التي أصبحت الآن شركة مطروحة للتداول العام ،
ولكن لماذا تعتبر آسيا
الصين هي المستورد الأول
للخام في جميع أنحاء العالم وكبار العملاء الآخرين
لمصدري الشرق الأوسط
تسميها كوريا الجنوبية واليابان.  تأثير تموج آسيا
الذي يعود إلى
مناطق فيروس كورونا جون تيفت أعمال سي إن إن
ريا